la parola dio ha spesso alimentato
conflitti guerre violenza
altre volte anche attivato stati d'animo
di paura e di angoscia come pure non
raramente ha portato a evadere dalla
concretezza della realtà
la vicenda umana di gesù di nazareth e
racconta di un dio capovolto un dio che
frantuma il concetto di onnipotenza e lo
riorganizza attorno alla dimensione
della mitezza e quando dico mitezza
intendo quello stato d'essere per cui
uno gioise del fatto che esistono gli
altri quello stato di vita quella
predisposizione a far sì che l'altro
viva che l'altro esista addirittura che
l'altro abbia più spazio addirittura di
me che grazie all'altro io esisto e
senza l'altro non c'è niente di me e
senza l'altro mi disintegro e allora
dentro la dimensione della mitezza e
chiaro che l'altro è un compagno di
viaggio mai un competitor è un amico e
non un avversario
alla luce di questa riorganizzazione del
concetto di onnipotenza come mitezza
come gioia per resistere
ecco che allora anche il credere nel dio
di gesù di nazaret è un'operazione
estremamente esistenziale un'operazione
che coinvolge la vita la storia è un
atto di concretezza che ha il suo dna la
sua struttura portante attorno alla
dimensione della passarsi per cui
credere incredibilmente a un fare è un
portarsi sul terreno dell'altro è un
portarsi al livello dell'altro è un
rendersi uguali è l'operazione più
difficile e proprio rendersi uguali e
portarsi sul terreno dell'altro con la
gioia di sentire che l'altro è la mia
adrenalina la mia
forza è la mia vita e concretamente
diamo un nome a questo abbassarsi vuol
dire attivare la dimensione
dell'ascoltare del dialogare della
solidarietà che non vanno declinate però
come un impegno etico come un impegno
per far del bene ma vanno attivate come
condizione esistenziale per cui il
abbassarsi al livello dell'altro gioire
per l'esistenza dell'altro
non è un'operazione etica di buon cuore
è la condizione per poter gustarsi la
vita perché vedete il laghetto di
narciso è un laghetto che custodisce la
morte quando leggo ingrandisce se stesso
si dilata a un certo punto sente
soltanto l'eco della propria parola
l'eco delle proprie sensazioni
l'eco delle proprie performance ed è
terribile quando l'unica parola che ti
ritorna alla tua quando l'unica
sensazione alla tua quando l'unica
operazione legittima è quella che fai tu
è terribile e quindi quando leggo leggo
diventa eco leggo divora se stesso
implode e si viva e si devasta si
frantuma e allora mi piace pensare che
l'esperienza credente è una profonda
operazione di umanizzazione è
un'operazione ben essere un'operazione
benessere il rischio grande ad
intraprendere l'esperienza credente come
un'operazione etica non etica e
operazione di benessere è scoperta della
grande potenzialità che ha il mio
lasciarmi ferire dal volto dell'altro e
per quanto l'altro possa ferirmi meglio
ferito dall'altro che distrutto dal
laghetto di narciso dove ci sono io io
io la mia solitudine
io la mia angoscia io e la mia morte e
allora alla luce di tutto questo mi
piace pensare al divino quello narrato
dalla vicenda concreta umana storica di
gesù di nazaret come a un umano che
raggiunge il suo vertice
per cui per me è divino è quando l'umano
si fa perdonare
si fa amore per il nemico si fa gratuità
assoluta quando l'umano addirittura
riesce a mettere in gioco perfino
l'esistenza quello umano per me il
divino quindi non c'è più un opposizione
tra umano e divino come siamo soliti
pensare dire umano e dire l'opposto da
dino no dire umano è dire è parlare di
divino c'è una soluzione di continua tra
umano e divino c'è uno scambio un
interagire continuo per cui dentro il
divino io trovo l'umano dentro l'umano
trovo il divino per cui risalendo
l'umano arrivo al divino e se trovo il
divino essendo all'umano
a me piace tantissimo a questa
prospettiva di ridefinizione del volto
di dio attorno alla categoria dell'umano
mi piace tantissimo pensare a questa
idea della mitezza come forza come
energia
mi piace tantissimo pensare che l'esodo
da me in ascii armi incontrare dagli
occhi dalle mani dal volto dell'altro
non è un'operazione che mi impoverisce
ma che mi arricchisce e veramente mi
pare di una straordinaria attualità
percepire che questo dio dà qualità
l'umano dà spessore umano rendere umano
profondamente interessante e
profondamente vincente e allora vorrei
proprio spezzare una lancia anche per
una ridefinizione passando per questa
realtà dell'umanità di gesù una
ridefinizione anche nel concetto proprio
del credere dove il credere non è
un'operazione che coinvolge la
dimensione intellettiva
non è una operazione che coinvolge la
dimensione emotiva ma è un fare è un
fidarsi è un fidarsi dell'operazione
dell'affidarsi al volto dell'altro
riconoscendo che quel volto è la mia
forza con le vina tornino i volti ad
abitare la vita tornano i volti a
definirmi perché io sono l'altro in
questa prospettiva
vorrei riprendere anche il fatto che
viene verificata la vita del credente
anche a livello evangelico da una pagina
che io dico una pagina estremamente
laica estremamente poco religiosa come
la pagina di matteo 25 avevo fame e mi
hai dato da mangiare avevo sete mi hai
dato da bere
questa pagina definisce il credere sul
terreno proprio dell'esistenza sul
terreno della storia della concretezza
della storia ea me è veramente intriga
molto pensare un dio che è uscito da sé
si è portato al mio livello
ha frequentato il mio terreno si è
inabissato nel mio terreno in tutte le
sue dimensioni e ha bisogno di
interagire con me questo è l'altra
grande scoperta e novità un dio che ha
bisogno di interagire con me nella
categoria del bisogno normalmente noi
non la portiamo sul terreno di dio ma
noi possiamo portarla tranquillamente
sul terreno di dio perché quando si
tratta della mare la marea nel
riferimento all'altro il suo elemento
decisivo e portante il bisogno di chi
ama non è indigenza non è povertà non è
inadeguatezza il bisogno di chi ama e
forza sopraffina perché quando io dico
ho bisogno di te non faccia
un'affermazione di debolezza ma faccia
un'affermazione estremamente di potenza
e di forza ed è bellissimo pensare che
il dio cristiano non si vergogna di dire
io ho bisogno perché è il dio dell'amore
al dio dell'uscita il dio dell'esodo e
per me amare vuol dire questo portarsi
sul terreno dell'altro farlo vivere e
sentire che se vive lui esisto viceversa
se cancello lui cancello anche me e
allora mi pare estremamente interessante
invitarvi a entrare in questa dimensione
della prospettiva dell'umano di gesù di
nazaret
perché
a questo punto lo posso dire sei umano
se sì sei umano se ti rende vulnerabile
sei umano se hai il coraggio di
lasciarsi ferire sei umano se ha il
coraggio di ripartire dopo una ferita
sei umano
se non ti fa paura lasciarti ferire non
sei più umano cominci a implodere
cominci a disgregarsi quando la paura ti
attanaglia l'unica prospettiva che ti
resta è quella di ingrandire te stesso
l'unica prospettiva che ti resta è
quella della performance di affidarti
alla performance alla giocata solitaria
a te stesso e quando uno è affidato a se
stesso è morto non è vivo
penso forse di aver dato un piccolo
contributo a ripensare dio è un
piccolissimo assaggio un piccolissimo
contributo per cui son contento del mio
dio capovolto
spero che lo possano incontrare anche
altri e magari su questo terreno
iniziare un discorso di umanizzazione di
cui abbiamo estremo bisogno
grazie
[Applauso]